So is that Marc.
那是马克吗？
Yes, that's Marc speaking for Scott.
是的，那是马克在替斯科特说话。
So Scott, you were born without hearing, right?
斯科特，你是天生失聪，对吧？
That's correct. Even though my parents didn't know that until I was 18 months old.
没错。虽然我父母在我18个月大之前都不知道这一点。
This is a very strange interview because you can't hear and because I have a terrible cold, I can't speak.
这是一次非常奇怪的采访，因为你听不见，而且我得了重感冒，没法说话。
Marc gets the burden here.
马克要承担这份重任了。
Yeah.
是的。
I talked with Scott Krepel through his interpreter, Marc Holmes-- they were in a studio in Washington, DC-- about what happened when Scott was 11 or 12 and the government approved the use of cochlear implants in children. So Scott got an implant. He was excited. He thought he'd fit in better at school, have more friends, date girls. And of course, he tried to imagine what it would be like to hear.
我通过他的口译员马克·霍姆斯与斯科特·克雷佩尔进行了交谈——他们当时在华盛顿特区的一个演播室里——谈到了当斯科特11或12岁时，政府批准在儿童身上使用人工耳蜗的情况。于是斯科特接受了植入手术。他很兴奋。他以为自己能更好地融入学校，交更多的朋友，和女孩约会。当然，他也试图想象听到声音会是什么样子。
To be honest, I didn't know what to expect. The best analogy I can think of is maybe, I was hoping that it would be like that speech was like telepathy, instant thought transfer.
老实说，我不知道该期待什么。我能想到的最好的类比是，我当时希望那就像心灵感应一样，是一种瞬间的思想传递。
So he had the surgery and then he went to the audiologist to configure the device and what they do is that they hook up the implant to a machine.
所以他做了手术，然后去了听力学家那里调试设备，他们所做的就是把植入物连接到一台机器上。
To send different frequencies, pulses, to try and stimulate the different parts in my cochlea. Trying to figure out which one worked.
发送不同的频率、脉冲，试图刺激我耳蜗中的不同部位。试图找出哪一个有效。
And so the first sounds that you hear are those pulses?
所以你听到的第一个声音就是那些脉冲吗？
Yes.
是的。
And what do they sound like?
听起来像什么？
The first time I heard something, I can remember very vividly because it wasn't really-- it didn't feel like hearing. It felt more like a vibration in my whole body. I was sitting there and nothing was happening except for like a little thing that was tingling throughout my body. But eventually after a while, the vibrations localized to my ears.
我第一次听到什么的时候，记忆非常深刻，因为那真的——感觉不像是在听。感觉更像是全身都在震动。我坐在那儿，除了身体里有一种微微发麻的感觉外，什么也没发生。但最终过了一会儿，震动就定位到了我的耳朵。
Oh, I see. The first vibrations, you couldn't even tell that they were coming in through your ears.
噢，我明白了。最初的震动，你甚至分辨不出它们是通过你的耳朵传进来的。
Right. I didn't really know that it was sound itself at first. And eventually I came to realize, wait a minute, this must be it. The audiologist just sent me on my way with the cochlear implant on.
对。起初我真的不知道那就是声音本身。但最终我意识到，等一下，这一定就是声音。听力学家只是让我带着人工耳蜗回家了。
We can only make an educated guess what this really sounds like. As best as we understand it from people who could once hear and then later in life got the implants, there's a mechanical edge to the sound that you hear with these devices. Musical notes have to be nearly half an octave apart before you can tell the difference between the notes. Voices, people say that they sound like a robot Daffy Duck. But for Scott, his brain had never developed the neural pathways to process audio. There were two big problems that went beyond all of that.
我们只能推测这听起来到底是什么样子。据我们从那些曾经有听力后来植入人工耳蜗的人那里了解到的，用这些设备听到的声音有一种机械感。音符必须相隔近半个八度，你才能分辨出音符之间的区别。人们说人声听起来像机器鸭子达菲。但对于斯科特来说，他的大脑从未发育出处理音频的神经通路。还有两个比这更大的问题。
One was that I couldn't understand any of the sounds. It was just all noise that did not have any ability to distinguish.
一个是，我无法理解任何声音。那只是一堆我无法分辨的噪音。
Am I understanding you right, if someone was looking right at you and you were seeing their mouth moving, talking directly to you, you actually couldn't tell which of the sounds was the sound of their voice coming out of their mouth?
我理解得对吗，如果有人正看着你，而你看到他们的嘴在动，直接对你说话，你实际上无法分辨出哪些声音是他们嘴里发出的声音？
It would depend on the environment. Because if it was an environment where there was other noises, then I wouldn't really be able to pick out the person's voice from that background.
这取决于环境。因为如果是在有其他噪音的环境中，我就真的无法从背景中辨别出那个人的声音。
If a dog barked or a horn honked, he couldn't tell what the sounds were or what caused them. A doctor who does these implants told me about a very young patient of his, a child who got the implant and then would just flush the toilet over and over, kind of amazed to connect the sound that it made with the action of the thing that they were seeing.
如果狗叫或按喇叭，他无法分辨出那是什么声音或是什么东西发出的。一位做这些植入手术的医生告诉了我他的一位非常年轻的病人，那个孩子接受了植入手术，然后会一遍又一遍地冲厕所，因为能把他看到的动作和它发出的声音联系起来而感到惊讶。
I was interested in Scott because although I know lots of deaf people say they have no need to learn to hear and they're fine as they are and they frown on this procedure, Scott is somebody who wanted this to work. He imagined what is going to be like. And our show today, our radio show today is all stories where people are trying to make contact for the first time with something that they have never encountered or experienced. And Scott's situation seemed like a particularly harsh example of that. The reality was so far from what he had expected. His second big problem with implants was he didn't have the ability to ignore any sounds.
我对斯科特很感兴趣，因为虽然我知道很多聋哑人说他们不需要学习听力，他们这样挺好的，而且他们对这种手术持反对态度，但斯科特是一个希望手术成功的人。他想象过那会是什么样子。我们今天的节目，今天的广播节目全是关于人们试图第一次接触他们从未遇到或体验过的事物的报道。而斯科特的情况似乎是一个特别严酷的例子。现实远非他所料。他关于植入物的第二个大问题是，他无法忽略任何声音。
Well if you're sitting in your office and you listen carefully, you might hear things like the computer fan running, or your own movements, or for many different things. And most people have trained themselves to ignore those noises. I had none of that ability. So everything ended up overwhelming me without me being able to stop it or ignore it.
嗯，如果你坐在办公室里仔细听，你可能会听到电脑风扇运转的声音，或者你自己的动作声，或者其他各种各样的声音。大多数人都训练自己去忽略这些噪音。我完全没有这种能力。所以所有事情最终都让我不堪重负，而我却无法阻止或忽略它。
For somebody like Scott getting the implant as his age, his brain can never catch up and learn to process sound. After five years with the implant, it was still hard for him to focus if an air conditioner was on in the room. And as for recognizing words, if he was in a quiet room and his speech therapist would say a word to him, he could actually pick out the word from a list of words that were sitting in front of him, and that's about as good as it got. So at the end of high school, he stopped using the implant. He doesn't miss it. The only time he really liked it he says was that very first day when he had his first contact with sound.
像斯科特这样在这个年龄接受植入手术的人，他的大脑永远无法跟上并学会处理声音。植入人工耳蜗五年后，如果房间里开着空调，他仍然很难集中注意力。至于识别单词，如果他在一个安静的房间里，言语治疗师对他读一个词，他实际上能从面前的一系列单词中挑出那个词，这就是他能做到的最好程度了。所以高中毕业后，他停止使用人工耳蜗了。他不怀念它。他说他唯一真正喜欢它的时候就是他第一次接触声音的那第一天。
I think the first time I heard that was cool, things like, oh I can clink the cookie jar, but it got old very fast.
我觉得第一次听到那个很酷，比如，噢，我可以敲饼干罐，但这很快就变得乏味了。
Well today on our show, First Contact, we have three stories of people in that frightening, thrilling, first moment of encounter, that leap into the unknown. Mike Birbiglia talks about an achievement that was literally years in the making for him. We have somebody also chatting his way into the lives of people very far away in the middle of a war, we have scientists pondering exactly what we should say the very first time we find extraterrestrials to talk to, and what boneheaded things people want to say to them. From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, still with a little cold this week, but feeling just fine. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目《第一次接触》中，我们有三个关于人们处于那种令人恐惧、令人激动的第一次相遇时刻、迈向未知的故事。迈克·比尔比利亚谈论了一项对他来说确实是耗时多年才实现的成就。我们还有人聊到了他与远在战争中间的人们的生活，我们有科学家在思考我们第一次发现外星人时到底应该说些什么，以及人们想对他们说的那些愚蠢的话。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是由公共广播国际发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，这周还有点感冒，但感觉还不错。请继续收听。
OK, I don't know why this came to mind, out the blue actually. Three weeks ago I was walking down the street, it was nighttime, I was with the dog, and I thought of this. And literally loud I said out loud, "Oh god. Oh God, no, no, no." Here's what I remembered.
好的，我不知道为什么会想起这个，其实很突然。三周前我在街上走，是晚上，我带着狗，想到了这个。我甚至大声说了出来，“噢天哪。噢天哪，不，不，不。”这是我回忆起的。
In junior high school, I was really, really young. I tried to feel up a girl in front of her family. Somehow I thought I could get away with this. We were watching a Jerry Lewis movie on TV in their rec room. I remember that. I had never touched a girl before, so I don't know why I thought this was going to happen. Anyway, so when this came back to me, it was really just as horrifying. I mean, even as I talk about it now. It's just as horrifying as it should have been the day it happened. And I bring this all up to say, we are all so clueless as we learn about making out and sex and all that stuff. And we begin our show today with a story from Mike Birbiglia. Nothing explicit happens here at all, but it still might not be right for every young listener.
初中的时候，我真的，非常年轻。我试图在她家人面前摸一个女孩。不知怎么的，我觉得我可以逃脱惩罚。我们当时在她们的娱乐室看电视里的杰瑞·刘易斯电影。我记得。我之前从未碰过女孩，所以我不知道为什么我觉得这会发生。总之，当这件事浮现在脑海里时，真的依然令人震惊。我的意思是，即使我现在谈论它，也和它发生的那天一样令人震惊。我提起这一切是想说，我们在学习接吻、性以及所有这些事情时都太无知了。我们今天的节目以迈克·比尔比利亚的故事开始。这里没有任何露骨的内容，但可能并不适合每一位年轻听众。
In seventh grade people started making out with each other, and I remember this very well because I remember thinking people we know are making out with other people we know! But how? It just seemed like this alien ritual, where these two aliens kind of attach orifices all of a sudden. And I was like, I am not doing that. And collectively all the girls in my class were like, that is fine. You are not on the list. You are not exactly a first round draft pick for our new activity.
七年级的时候，人们开始接吻了，我对此记忆犹新，因为我记得当时在想，我们认识的人正在和我们认识的其他人和接吻！但怎么做呢？这看起来就像一种外星仪式，这两个外星人突然把孔连在了一起。我当时想，我才不干那事儿。我们班所有的女生一致认为，那很好。你不在名单上。对于我们这项新活动，你并不是第一轮选秀的优先人选。
It just seemed gross to me, making out. It's like watching a dog eat spaghetti. So I wasn't going to make out with anyone and I was fine with that. But then it started to sort of create factions in the seventh grade class, sort of the make out club and the non-make out club. I mean these weren't formal organizations, that would be very sad. A meeting of the non-make out club. I call this meeting to order. First order of business, Nintendo.
接吻对我来说看起来很恶心。就像看着一只狗吃意大利面。所以我才不和任何人接吻，我对此感觉很好。但后来七年级班级开始形成派别，类似于接吻俱乐部和非接吻俱乐部。我的意思是这些不是正式的组织，那会很可悲。非接吻俱乐部会议。我宣布会议开始。第一项议程，任天堂。
The non-make out club, we had a hard time because we were losing good people by the day. I feared that soon I would be the lone member of the non-make out club. So I was, I need to join the make out club. But I didn't have any real prospects. I mean I had this one girl who I had a huge crush on who sat in front of me in class named Lisa Bizetti. And she had to talk to me on the phone every night about homework thanks t alphabetical order. So one time I said something that made her laugh and I was like, oh, this is great. Like I gotta do that more. And then one time she was actually laughing so hard and she said, Mike, you gotta stop. I'm going to pee myself. I was like, wow. It was the closest I'd ever come to a vagina. So I spent the next 15 years trying to get Lisa  Bizetti to pee. And that's how I ended up here.
非接吻俱乐部，我们日子不好过，因为我们每天都在失去优秀的人才。我担心很快我就要成为非接吻俱乐部的唯一成员了。所以我当时想，我需要加入接吻俱乐部。但我没有任何真正的机会。我是说，我班上有个坐在我前面的女孩叫丽莎·比泽蒂，我暗恋她很久了。多亏了字母顺序，她每晚都得在电话里和我聊家庭作业。所以有一次我说了一些话把她逗笑了，我心想，噢，这太棒了。我得多那样做。还有一次她笑得太厉害了，她说，迈克，你得停下。我要尿裤子了。我当时想，哇。这是我离女性生殖器最近的一次。所以我花了接下来的15年试图让丽莎·比泽蒂尿出来。这就是我最后来到这里的原因。
So one time I built up the courage to ask Lisa to go to a carnival with me. And she said, yes. And I was so excited about this. I had this idea that we would go to the carnival and I would win her a giant stuffed bear. And we would go on rides, and then we'd make out. Like really simple, just like the romantic comedy montages. And I took her on a ride called the Scrambler. And I don't know if you have the Scrambler where you live. I imagine you do. It travels on a truck.
有一次，我鼓起勇气邀请丽莎和我一起去嘉年华。她说，好。我对此感到非常兴奋。我有一个想法，就是我们会去嘉年华，我会为她赢得一只巨大的填充熊。我们会坐游乐设施，然后接吻。真的很简单，就像浪漫喜剧里的蒙太奇片段。我带她坐了一个叫“摇晃者”的游乐设施。我不知道你们住的地方有没有“摇晃者”。我想你们会有。它是在卡车上运输的。
The premise is that you sit on the two-person pod with the person you're in love with, and then that pod goes in a circle. Which is part of an even larger circle, which is part of an even grander circle. As I understand it, it was originally designed as a medical device for people who have sharp objects stuck in their throat to help them purge the objects. It was called a Puke Your Facerator. And it was very successful. And then it was co-opted by the carnival workers of America-- CWoA.
前提是你要和你心爱的人坐在双人舱里，然后那个舱会绕圈。这是一个更大圆圈的一部分，而那个大圆圈又是更宏伟圆圈的一部分。据我所知，它最初是为喉咙里有尖锐物体的人设计的医疗设备，帮助他们清除物体。它被称为“呕吐加速器”。它非常成功。然后它被美国嘉年华工会——CWoA——接管了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And they said, we like it, but we feel like the name is something of a turn off. And then one guy goes, well, what about the Scrambler? And they're like, nailed it. But who is going to be in charge of this dangerous piece of equipment? And then one guy goes, well, I have a nephew who's 16-years-old and smokes pot 24 hours a day. I feel like he might be available. And they're like, he sounds amazing. We don't even need to interview him. He sounds completely qualified.
他们说，我们喜欢它，但我们觉得这个名字有点让人倒胃口。然后一个人说，那么，叫“摇晃者”怎么样？他们说，完美。但谁来负责这台危险的设备呢？然后一个人说，嗯，我有个16岁的侄子，每天24小时抽大麻。我觉得他可能有空。他们说，他听起来棒极了。我们甚至不需要面试他。他听起来完全合格。
So we sit down on the Scrambler and Lisa's snuggling up next to me. And I was thinking, like, this is it. This is where it's at all going to happen. But I think that when you're 12-years-old, you just don't understand certain things about the digestive system. You don't know that you shouldn't eat popcorn and peanuts and funnel cake and cotton candy and then go on a machine that scrambles your body. Cotton candy being the most insane of these items.
所以我们坐在“摇晃者”上，丽莎紧挨着我。我想，就是现在。这一切都要发生了。但我觉得当你12岁时，你就是不懂消化系统的某些事情。你不知道你不应该在吃爆米花、花生、漏斗蛋糕和棉花糖之后，去坐一台把你身体摇得乱七八糟的机器。棉花糖是这些东西里最疯狂的。
It's basically like saying, we're going to take sugar, which everyone knows is bad. But then we'll dress it up like insulation. And I'm like, I'm not sure what he selling point is there. Is it the sugar or the insulation? So I know from the moment they put the bar seat belt down that I am going to throw up for sure. The bar seat belt is not a very reassuring piece of safety equipment. That has never saved anyone's life. I mean, come one. I mean I think the only thing it's ever done right is just held someone's esophagus down to the pavement in a Scrambler accident, making sure that they are dead, and that they can not talk about the Scrambler accident
这基本上就像在说，我们要吃糖，大家都知道糖不好。但我们会把它打扮成隔热材料。我就想，我不确定那里的卖点是什么。是糖还是隔热材料？所以我从他们放下栅栏安全带的那一刻起，我就知道我肯定会吐出来。栅栏安全带并不是一种让人很放心的安全设备。那从未救过任何人的命。我的意思是，拜托。我想它唯一做对的事就是把某人的食道压在“摇晃者”事故的人行道上，确保他们已经死了，这样他们就不能谈论“摇晃者”事故了。
I know when they put the bar seatbelt down I'm going to throw up for sure. And I even say to the Scrambler operator, I'm like, hey, actually-- and then he was gone. Apparently he doesn't enjoy the second halves of sentences.
当他们放下栅栏安全带时，我就知道我肯定会吐出来。我甚至对“摇晃者”的操作员说，我说，嘿，其实——然后他就走了。显然他不享受句子的后半部分。
And so then I'm scrambling. And I'm scrambling and I'm thinking, I need to come up with a plan of some kind. And my first plan was that I wouldn't look at Lisa and I wouldn't look at any other people. So I'm like, don't look at Lisa. Don't look at any other people. Don't look at Lisa. Don't look at any other people. I need a new plan. And the new plan was that I needed to tell the Scrambler operator that he needed to stop the ride. But the mathematics of the Scrambler are such that the window of opportunity in which one can communicate with the Scrambler operator is a very limited window. So I'm like, I got to the guy to stop the ride. I got to tell the guy to stop the ride. I got to tell the guy to stop the ride. Please stop the ride. And then I'm back. 20 yards away, 30 yards away, 40 hours away, 20 yards away. I got to say it louder. Please stop the ride!. And I'm back. 20 yards away, 30 yards away, 40 yards away. I'm like, I'm not sure he's paying attention. I think he might be smoking pot right now. And the third time I said, please stop the-- and then I started throwing up. And it was not unlike an oscillating lawn sprinkler. You know, just [SPRINKLER NOISES]. Just popcorn and peanuts and insulation. Really insulating the pavement with my homemade carnival salsa.
所以我开始晃动。我一边晃一边想，我得想个计划什么的。我的第一个计划是我不看丽莎，也不看其他人。所以我想，别看丽莎。别看其他人。别看丽莎。别看其他人。我需要一个新计划。新计划是我需要告诉“摇晃者”操作员他需要停下这台游乐设施。但“摇晃者”的数学原理是，可以与操作员沟通的时间窗口非常有限。所以我心想，我得让那个人停下机器。我得告诉那个人停下机器。我得告诉那个人停下机器。请停下机器。然后我又晃回去了。20码外，30码外，40码外，20码外。我得大声说。请停下机器！然后我又晃回去了。20码外，30码外，40码外。我心想，我不确定他在注意。我觉得他现在可能在抽大麻。第三次我说，请停下——然后我开始呕吐。这就像一个摆动的草坪喷水器。你知道，就是[喷水声]。全是爆米花、花生和隔热材料。真的用我自制的嘉年华莎莎酱铺满了人行道。
And I did not look at Lisa, but I'm pretty sure she was staring at me. And we did not make out. Making out was no longer on the agenda that evening. And so I did not lose my mouth virginity.
我没有看丽莎，但我很确定她在盯着我。我们没有接吻。那天晚上接吻已不再议程上了。所以我没有失去我的初吻。
But the next year, it actually got worse. Because I went to an all boys catholic school and I actually couldn't admit to my peers that I hadn't had my first kiss because I knew they would make fun of me mercilessly. And so when they would ask, I would just be like, yeah. And I feared that at some point they would ask follow up questions. They'd be like, oh yeah, what's it like? And I'd be like, it's like licking an ice cream cone. And they'd be like, no it's not. It's like sucking on a rocket pop. And I'd be like, oh, wrong frozen dessert analogy.
但第二年，情况反而更糟了。因为我上了一所全男生天主教学校，我实际上无法向同龄人承认我还没有过初吻，因为我知道他们会无情地嘲笑我。所以当他们问起时，我就只会说，是啊。我担心他们会在某个时候问后续问题。他们会说，噢是啊，感觉怎么样？我会说，就像舔冰淇淋蛋筒。他们会说，不，不是。就像吸火箭棒棒冰。我会说，噢，冷冻甜点比喻错了。
Because these guys that I went to school with, I mean they were just make out machines. I mean I sat behind this one guy in class named Sam Richiarti and he was like a make out ninja. Like every Monday morning I'd be like, what'd you do over the weekend? And he would just be like, made out with chicks. And I would be like, where? And he would be like, the mall, dude. The mall. As though that made sense. And I was just trying to imagine this, like the mall. What does that mean? He goes to the arcade and kind of like throws quarters around to the ladies. And then, invites one over to go to Orange Julius. And then says, hey, want to make out at the phone booth or whatever? Like I don't even know how that happens.
因为我和他们一起上学的这些家伙，我的意思是他们简直是接吻机器。我坐在班里一个叫山姆·里奇亚蒂的家伙后面，他简直是个接吻忍者。就像每个周一早上我都会问，周末干嘛了？他就会说，和辣妹接吻了。我会问，在哪？他会说，商场，伙计。商场。好像这很有道理。我当时只是试图想象那个场景，比如商场。那意味着什么？他去游戏厅，然后像对女士们撒硬币一样。然后，邀请一个去喝橙汁。然后说，嘿，想在电话亭接吻吗？诸如此类的？我甚至不知道那是怎么发生的。
So I thought my only chance to lose my mouth virginity was going to be at the annual St. John's dance. They had what they called cattle call dances where they invite all the girls from all over the state to the St. John's gymnasium for the sole purpose of making out. I mean this was a gymnasium that was chock full of sweat and Binaca and Led Zeppelin and Drakkar Noir and I was flanked at the dance by my friend Sam. And we were introduced by our friend, Tom, to this girl, these two girls. And Sam said one of those phrases that we've all heard, but is very uncomfortable. He said, you get that one. Which I know is uncomfortable to talk about, but I'm OK talking about it because I know I've been on the negative end of that conversation where some girls says of me like, you get that one. And then the other girl goes, ew. Or even worse, you owe me. Which really hurts. You know, thinking about someone incurring debt based on my appearance. I don't want to hurt someone's credit score.
所以我以为我失去初吻的唯一机会是在圣约翰年度舞会上。他们有种叫“选牛大会”的舞会，他们会邀请全州各地的女孩来圣约翰体育馆，目的就是接吻。那是一个充斥着汗水、Binaca口气喷雾、齐柏林飞艇乐队和Drakkar Noir古龙水的体育馆，我的朋友山姆在我身边。我们的朋友汤姆把我们介绍给了这个女孩，这两个女孩。山姆说了那句我们都听过，但非常尴尬的短语。他说，那个归你了。我知道谈论这个很尴尬，但我没问题，因为我知道我曾处于这种对话的消极一方，当时有些女孩指着我说，那个归你了。然后另一个女孩说，呃。或者更糟，你欠我的。这真的伤人。你知道，想到有人因为我的外貌而产生债务。我不想损害别人的信用评分。
So he says, you get that one. And then I'm fast-dancing with this girl, Sandra. I'm not great at fast-dancing. She's losing interest in me by the second. And I'm saved by a slow song. It was "Stairway to Heaven." It's an eight-minute make out anthem. And we're slow dancing and you can't mess up slow dancing because it's just kind of a slow motion hug. The only way you could mess it up is if you started fast dancing in the middle of it. And she was like, what are you doing? And I'm like, I don't pick up on social cues.
所以他说，那个归你了。然后我正和这个女孩桑德拉跳快舞。我不太擅长跳快舞。她每秒钟都在对我失去兴趣。慢歌救了我。那是《天堂的阶梯》。这首八分钟的接吻国歌。我们慢舞，你没法把慢舞搞砸，因为那只是一种慢动作拥抱。你唯一能搞砸的方法就是如果在中间开始跳快舞。她当时问，你在干什么？我说，我不懂社交暗示。
So we're slow dancing and all I'm focused on is I just don't want to fidget too much. Because I'm kind of a fidgety person. I fear if I fidget too much I could initiate the tilt too early. That's one of the main ingredients of making out, the tilt. And then the area in between the two mouths, which is a very mysterious area. I mean no one has video footage of that area. It's like the giant squid of making out. No one has seen it alive, they've just seen it washed up on shore. Which is more specific to the squid side of the analogy. You know what I mean? And so, with about three minutes left in "Stairway to Heaven" I make the slightest tilt and then Sandra comes in strong. And then it was an all out mouth war. And she had artillery because she had braces. It was like a dog eating spaghetti and the fork.
所以我们在慢舞，我关心的只是不想太烦躁。因为我是一个容易烦躁的人。我担心如果我太烦躁，可能会过早地发起倾斜。那是接吻的主要成分之一，倾斜。然后是两个嘴唇之间的区域，那是一个非常神秘的区域。我的意思是没人有那个区域的视频资料。它就像接吻界的巨大乌贼。没人见过它活着的样子，只见过它冲上岸的样子。这更符合乌贼比喻的那一面。你知道我的意思吗？所以，在《天堂的阶梯》还剩三分钟时，我做了最轻微的倾斜，然后桑德拉主动凑了过来。那简直是一场全面的嘴仗。她有武器，因为她戴着牙套。那感觉就像一只狗在吃意大利面，连叉子一起吃了。
And while this oral atrocity is taking place, all I can think is, I'm not alone anymore. I'm not in the non-make out club. And it was this real seminal moment for me. But I couldn't share it with anyone because I walked off the dance floor and I had to play it off like this was something I had done before. My friend Sam was like, how'd it go? And I was just like, it was great, just like always.
当这种口腔暴行发生时，我能想到的只有，我不再孤单了。我不在非接吻俱乐部了。这对我也确实是一个决定性的时刻。但我无法与任何人分享，因为我走下舞池，我必须假装这我已经做过。我的朋友山姆问，怎么样？我就说，棒极了，和往常一样。
So a few days later I call Sandra and I'm thinking, maybe we could have a relationship of some kind. And she doesn't call me back. And so I go to school one day and I say to my friend Tom who had introduced us, I go, hey, what's going on with Sandra? And he has this kind of knowing grin on his face. I'm like, what? He's like, nothing. I was like, what? And he's like, nothing. And I was like, what? And he was like, oh, I talked to Sandra and she said that you're the worst kisser she's ever kissed.
几天后我打电话给桑德拉，我想，也许我们可以建立某种关系。但她没有回电。有一天我去学校，对我介绍我们认识的朋友汤姆说，嘿，桑德拉那边怎么样了？他脸上带着一种了然的坏笑。我问，怎么了？他说，没事。我说，什么？他说，没事。我说，什么？他说，噢，我跟桑德拉聊了，她说你是她吻过的人里技术最差的一个。
I know. It was devastating. Because first of all, because it was probably true. But more importantly, because I couldn't explain to my friends why it was true. I couldn't do like, well that makes sense because I've never kissed anyone before. I had no idea what I'm doing. So instead, I had to just be like, yeah, that sounds about right. I'm a terrible kisser. That's kind of my thing. But I was lucky because my friend Sam was right there with me and he's goes, me too, dude. Me too.
我知道。这太令人崩溃了。因为首先，因为这很可能是真的。但更重要的是，因为我无法向朋友解释为什么这是真的。我不能说，噢，那很正常，因为我以前从未亲过任何人。我根本不知道我在做什么。所以相反，我只能说，是啊，听起来确实如此。我接吻技术很烂。那是我的招牌。但我很幸运，因为我的朋友山姆就在我身边，他说，我也是，伙计。我也是。
Mike Birbiglia, performing a story from his new one-man show and his new book that is coming out this fall. The book is Sleepwalk with Me and Other Painfully True Stories.
迈克·比尔比利亚，表演来自他新的个人秀和他即将在今年秋天出版的新书中的故事。书名是《梦游》以及其他痛苦的真实故事。
Coming up, mistakes we've made with space aliens. Already, we don't even know them and we've made mistakes. That's in a minute. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，我们在外星人身上犯下的错误。还没开始，我们甚至还不认识他们，就已经犯错了。一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, First Contact, stories about people reaching outside what they know, outside their comfort zone, making contact with something they have only heard about. We've arrived at act 2 of our show. Act two: brothers from another planet.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你们关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，《第一次接触》，关于人们接触他们已知事物之外，舒适区之外的事物，接触那些他们只听说过的事物。我们节目进入了第二幕。第二幕：来自另一个星球的兄弟。
What's amazing about this next story is that this couple befriends these strangers. Mostly the guy, but also the woman. And really, they get to know them and what their lives are really like at this level that is so intimate. It takes them into this world that most of us really don't feel like we have any access to at all. Here's Sara Blaisdell, who tells the story.
下一个故事令人惊奇的是，这对夫妇与这些陌生人成为了朋友。主要是那个男人，但也包括那个女人。他们真的了解他们，了解他们的生活在这样一个如此亲密的层面上是怎样的。这把他们带入了大多数人感觉根本无法触及的世界。这是莎拉·布莱斯代尔，她讲述了这个故事。
Here's what I know about Yemal from the pictures. When it's cold, which isn't often, he wears grey and red stripe sweaters. He can do a cartwheel. He likes to hold babies, stand next to camels, and sit on saggy couches conversing with handsome young men. He himself, is handsome. His big brown eyes, thick dark hair, a mischeivous-looking moustache, a three-days beard, and a tiny gap between his front teeth. He's the kind of guy who wholeheartedly smiles in photos, rather than trying to look like a bad-ass.
这就是我通过照片了解到的关于耶马尔的情况。天冷的时候，虽然这种情况不多，他会穿灰红相间的条纹毛衣。他会做侧手翻。他喜欢抱着婴儿，站在骆驼旁边，坐在下垂的沙发上与英俊的年轻人交谈。他本人，很帅。他那双棕色的大眼睛，浓密的黑发，看起来有点调皮的小胡子，三天的胡茬，还有门牙间的一道小缝。他是那种在照片里会由衷微笑，而不是试图看起来像个硬汉的家伙。
Yemal lives near Sadr City, a poor section in Northeast Baghdad. He's the oldest of three Iraqi brothers and he's aged from 17 to 23 since the war started in 2003. The same year he and my husband, Sam Taylor, started their Sunday phone ritual. When Yemal looks back at what's happened during this time he says, there haven't been any positive things because of the war. But there have been many positive things happening during the war. You know, I got married. I got my children. I met Sam.
耶马尔住在巴格达东北部一个贫穷的地区萨德尔城。他是三个伊拉克兄弟中的老大，自2003年战争开始以来，他从17岁长到了23岁。也是在同一年，他和我的丈夫萨姆·泰勒开始了他们的周日电话仪式。当耶马尔回顾这段时间发生的事情时，他说，因为战争，没有任何积极的事情。但在战争期间确实发生了很多积极的事情。你知道，我结婚了。我有了孩子。我认识了萨姆。
On a recent Saturday night, Sam was up late playing Call of Duty on Xbox Live with friends, and then watching sci-fi films and eating chicken wings with me. But he knows he will piss off at least three Iraqis if he's not up by 7:50 Sunday morning. So he sets the alarm. Then clicks it off when it beeps just five hours later. Gets his headset ready, starts the coffee. Then the phone rings, like it has almost every week since 2003. Sam's been talking to the boys as we call them, Yemal, Sadeem and Mahmood for at least four hours every Sunday for almost seven years.
最近的一个周六晚上，萨姆很晚才睡，在Xbox Live上和朋友玩《使命召唤》，然后和我一起看科幻电影吃鸡翅。但他知道如果周日早上7点50分不起床，他会惹恼至少三个伊拉克人。所以他定了闹钟。然后在五小时后闹钟响时把它按掉。准备好耳机，开始煮咖啡。然后电话响了，就像2003年以来几乎每周那样。萨姆和我们称之为“男孩们”的人——耶马尔、萨迪姆和马哈茂德——每周至少谈话四个小时，已经持续了近七年。
But on this Sunday, March 28, 2010, when Sam answers the phone, Yemal is unusually quite, not really engaged. This is about the time Yemal's wife, Temara , is supposed to be having her baby. So Sam worries something's gone wrong.
但在2010年3月28日这个周日，当萨姆接听电话时，耶马尔异常安静，并没有真正投入。这大约是耶马尔的妻子特马拉预产期的时间。所以萨姆担心出了什么问题。
I'm not sure how to say this, Yemal says, then he gets quite again.
我不知道该怎么说，耶马尔说，然后他又安静了下来。
Are you there, Sam asks?
你在听吗？萨姆问。
I'm trying to think of what to say. I'm trying to get the strength to say this.
我在想该说什么。我正在努力鼓起勇气说出来。
This whole time Sam's thinking, the new baby has died, Temara has died, or both. He thinks for sure that's what it is and he doesn't know how he's going to respond.
这段时间萨姆一直在想，新生儿死了，特马拉死了，或者两者都死了。他觉得肯定是这样，他不知道该如何回应。
And then Yemal says, you lied.
然后耶马尔说，你撒谎了。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
You said that if enough people voted, al-Maliki would be gone and Allawi would win.
你说过如果足够多的人投票，马利基就会下台，阿拉维就会赢。
A few hours later, Sam and I are making a rare Sunday lunch together because the boys hung up earlier than usual. Maybe because of their sour moods.
几个小时后，萨姆和我正在一起吃一顿罕见的周日午餐，因为男孩们比平时更早挂断了电话。也许是因为他们心情不好。
Did you tell them Allawi would win?, I ask.
你告诉他们阿拉维会赢吗？我问。
Kind of, Sam says. Well, not exactly. Sam had told them that if people didn't like al-Maliki and enough people voted, they might get him out. He could be gone. He hadn't meant for it to be a stump speech about the power of democracy. He hadn't meant it as a property either. And now it's all over the news, Nouri al-Maliki saying something to the effect of as Yemal puts it, I am in power. I will always be in power.
算吧，萨姆说。嗯，也不完全是。萨姆曾告诉他们，如果人们不喜欢马利基并且有足够多的人投票，他们可能会让他下台。他可能会走人。他本意并不是要发表关于民主力量的竞选演说。他也没打算做预言。而现在新闻里到处都是，努里·马利基说了一些类似于——正如耶马尔所说——我掌握权力。我将永远掌握权力。
After Yemal accused Sam of being a liar, they talked through it. They always managed to talk through it after one or the other unwittingly offends, or after they've delved too deep into dark topics. They usually warm up again by talking about light stuff or joking about stereotypes of East and West.
在耶马尔指责萨姆是骗子后，他们商量通了。他们总能在其中一方无意冒犯，或深入探讨黑暗话题后商量通。他们通常会通过谈论轻松的事情或开玩笑调侃东西方刻板印象来重新热络起来。
Sam will be talking about Jews, for example, and Yemal will say, Jews? But he'll say it like Jews. And Sam will say, that's so cliche. The Middle Easterner's got to hate the Jews. Or Yemal jokes about how sinful Sam is. He'll give him a hard time because he had sex before marriage, or he'll ask, were you drinking last night?
例如，萨姆会谈论犹太人，而耶马尔会说，犹太人？但他会说成“犹太人”。萨姆会说，这太陈词滥调了。中东人就得恨犹太人。或者耶马尔会开玩笑说萨姆有多罪恶。他会因为他婚前有性行为而给他难堪，或者他会问，你昨晚喝酒了吗？
The boys are also really interested in finding videos on YouTube of world leaders crying, world leaders doing something embarrassing. Especially Arab leaders, but others too. They tell Sam, oh, there's this new Ahmadinejad rap you have to hear. It's so funny.
男孩们也对在YouTube上寻找世界领导人哭泣、做尴尬事情的视频非常感兴趣。特别是阿拉伯领导人，但也包括其他人。他们告诉萨姆，噢，有这个新的艾哈迈迪内贾德饶舌视频你一定要听。太搞笑了。
The boys usually lead the conversation and Sam usually follows. They'll talk about political news, family news, works news. Since Yemal was conscripted into the army, cleaning up after suicide bombings is a regular part of his life. When they talked about the violent, Sam used to say stuff like, maybe this'll be over soon, or things are going to get better. But he stopped saying that. Now mostly he'll just listen and won't try to explain it away. A lot of times they're looking for answers to questions like, how would you feel if this was happening to you? Let's say your wife got killed. So Sam will say I don't know how I would feel. Because he doesn't.
男孩们通常引导对话，萨姆通常跟进。他们会谈论政治新闻、家庭新闻、工作新闻。由于耶马尔被征召入伍，清理自杀式爆炸后的现场是他生活的一部分。当他们谈论暴力时，萨姆曾经会说，也许这很快就会结束，或者情况会变好。但他不再那样说了。现在他大多只是倾听，不会试图找借口。很多时候，他们是在寻找诸如“如果这发生在你身上，你会怎么感觉？”之类问题的答案。比如说你的妻子被杀了。所以萨姆会说我不知道我会怎么感觉。因为他确实不知道。
Sam first met Yemal in 2003. At the time, Sam was a philosophy undergrad living in Pleasant Grove Utah. He was kind of bored with the politics website he was arguing on, so he started playing around with this chat program and met an Israeli there. Acrosstheuniverse was his user name.
萨姆第一次见到耶马尔是在2003年。当时，萨姆是犹他州普莱森特格罗夫的一名哲学系本科生。他对他争论的政治网站有点厌烦，所以他开始玩这个聊天程序，并在那里遇到了一个以色列人。Acrosstheuniverse是他的用户名。
On Sam's campus there are wide screen TVs all over the food court blasting the war news. One day Sam distinctly remembers there was coverage of the explosions, bombs hitting Iraq. It was like they were watching a football game Sam says. It seemed wrong to him. So he asked his Israeli chat buddy, Acrosstheuniverse, what he thought about the war. What did he think was going to come of it. Acrosstheuniverse replied, I just met an Iraqi. Want to meet him? Sure, Sam said. So that's when he got a message from Yemal, a real live Iraqi.
在萨姆的校园里，美食广场到处都是巨大的屏幕，播放着战争新闻。有一天，萨姆清楚地记得，有关于爆炸、炸弹袭击伊拉克的报道。萨姆说，这就像他们在看足球比赛一样。对他来说这似乎不对。所以他问他的以色列聊天伙伴Acrosstheuniverse，他是怎么看待这场战争的。他认为结果会怎样。Acrosstheuniverse回答说，我刚认识一个伊拉克人。想见见他吗？当然，萨姆说。所以那是他收到耶马尔的消息的时候，一个真正的伊拉克人。
So he started asking him about the war, about what was going on outside his window. Yemal wrote back about the pro-democracy propaganda flyers written in English. They were floating down onto the streets. Within a couple of weeks, they were writing each other about more personal stuff.
所以他开始问他关于战争的事，关于他窗外正在发生的事。耶马尔回信写到了用英语写的支持民主的宣传传单。它们正飘落在街上。几周之内，他们就开始互通关于更私人的事情了。
Half a year went by and Yemal bought a calling card and asked Sam for his phone number. Then early one morning the phone rang and all of a sudden Sam was speaking to someone whose voice he couldn't quite place, with an accent crisp and formal, like none he'd ever heard.
半年过去了，耶马尔买了电话卡，问萨姆要了电话号码。那天清晨，电话响了，萨姆突然和一个他声音有点陌生的人说话，带着一种干脆而正式的口音，是他从未听过的。
The calls started coming in a little bit more when Sam met Yemal's younger brothers, Sadeem and Mahmood. Talking was a way to pass the time when it was too dangerous to go out on the streets. Sometimes when Yemal and Sadeem and their parents had to leave the house, Yemal would ask Sam to babysit Mahmood over the phone. Just talk to him and keep him company in case he got scared.
当萨姆认识了耶马尔的弟弟萨迪姆和马哈茂德时，电话开始多起来。在街上太危险的时候，谈话成了消磨时间的一种方式。有时当耶马尔和萨迪姆以及他们的父母不得不离开房子时，耶马尔会让萨姆在电话里照顾马哈茂德。只是和他说话，让他保持陪伴，以防他害怕。
Sadeem's the middle kid. Three years younger than Yemal and three years older than Mahmood. Sam remembers a few days he and Sadeem just talked all day. From early in the morning till the evening when it started getting dark.
萨迪姆是中间的孩子。比耶马尔小三岁，比马哈茂德大三岁。萨姆记得有几天他和萨迪姆整天都在聊天。从一大早一直聊到天黑下来。
In their early phone calls, Sadeem read Sam [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and several Iraqi poets. I was working at a teen clinic for girls at the time and as Sadeem reached 15, he would send the girls poems he'd written about life in Iraq. They'd respond by writing meth poems and heroin poems. And send Sadeem little construction paper cards that said, thank you for your service. Sadeem told me, make sure you show those girls my picture so they know how cute I am. And he was cute. Red soccer jerseys, curly dark hair, big eyes with long lashes.
在他们早期的通话中，萨迪姆给萨姆读了[未听清]和几位伊拉克诗人的诗。我当时在一家少女诊所工作，当萨迪姆长到15岁时，他会给女孩们寄去他写的关于伊拉克生活的诗。她们会用写冰毒诗和海洛因诗来回应。并给萨迪姆寄去写着“感谢你的服务”的小建筑纸卡。萨迪姆告诉我，一定要给那些女孩看我的照片，这样她们就知道我有多可爱了。他确实很可爱。红色的足球衫，卷曲的黑发，大眼睛长睫毛。
When things got bad though, after Sadeem and Mahmood were injured for the first time by a suicide bombing in 2005, Sadeem started asking me questions like, where do those girls you work with cut on their arms? And how do you fix PTSD? He'd say he was going to hurt himself, and then he'd hang up on us. Then call back a few minutes later and apologize.
然而当情况恶化时，在萨迪姆和马哈茂德于2005年第一次被自杀式爆炸伤害后，萨迪姆开始问我诸如“那些和你一起工作的女孩手臂上是怎么割伤的？你是怎么治好创伤后应激障碍的？”之类的问题。他说他要自残，然后就会挂断我们的电话。然后几分钟后又打回来道歉。
March 8, 2010 when I answer the phone, Yemal says, it was a horrible day yesterday. The media will tell you the elections were a [BLEEP] damn success. But there's no success when people die.
2010年3月8日，当我接听电话时，耶马尔说，昨天是糟糕的一天。媒体会告诉你选举是[哔]该死的成功。但当人们死亡时，就没有成功。
He's on the bus home coming from just west of the green zone, where his brother, Mahmood, lives with their parents. Yesterday, Mahmood had been walking down the street and there was a bomb explosion. He came home with a hand just hanging and said that hurt, Yemal says. And I said, I understand why because it's broken. So he had to go to the hospital. But he's home now. Can you hold on a minute? I'm getting off the bus. Sure, I say.
他在回家的公交车上，从绿区以西刚出来，那是他弟弟马哈茂德和父母住的地方。昨天，马哈茂德走在街上，发生了炸弹爆炸。他回家时手都耷拉着说那很疼，耶马尔说。我说，我明白为什么因为骨折了。所以他不得不去医院。但他现在回家了。你能等一下吗？我要下车了。当然，我说。
It's a Monday. I talked to the boys sometimes by phone and e-mail, but didn't ask to talk yesterday because I didn't want to mess Mahmood's Sunday's scheduling. Mahmood is 16 and it's his self-proclaimed duty to make sure everyone gets equal time with Sam. He even sets an alarm that goes off when one person's turn is finished, so the next one can start.
这是一个周一。我有时通过电话和电子邮件与男孩们交谈，但昨天没要求谈话，因为我不想破坏马哈茂德的周日安排。马哈茂德16岁，他的自称职责是确保每个人都能和萨姆有平等的谈话时间。他甚至设置了一个闹钟，当一个人的时间结束时就会响，这样下一个人就可以开始了。
When I ask how Mahmood is doing other than the broken arm, Yemal says, as you know, this year he got a girlfriend and got engaged. And then she got killed in a suicide bombing. It goes up and down with him. He still has lots of nightmare.
当我问马哈茂德除了骨折外怎么样时，耶马尔说，你知道，今年他交了个女朋友并订婚了。然后她在一次自杀式爆炸中被杀了。他的情绪起伏很大。他仍然有很多噩梦。
Yemal believes that of the three boys, Mahmood's most affected by the war. He doesn't remember the Iran-Iraq War or the Kuwait War, and he was too little to remember the deaths caused by the oil for food program the way Yemal does. So when Mahmood was nine in 2003 and the war started, he'd never really been around bombs. So, Yemal says, he's the most scared.
耶马尔认为，在三个男孩中，马哈茂德受战争的影响最大。他不记得两伊战争或科威特战争，他也太小了，不记得像耶马尔那样由于石油换食品计划造成的死亡。所以当马哈茂德在2003年9岁时战争开始，他从未真正接触过炸弹。所以，耶马尔说，他最害怕。
Mahmood is the one Sam talks with most on days other than the scheduled Sundays. We'll be in the line at the grocery store and Mahmood will text, I'm scared, Yam. I can't sleep. He's got this little Elmo voice. It's matured slightly over the years, but you can almost here that tiny Elmo sound when you read his text messages. Sometimes he'll just write, Yam? Yam? He's been calling Sam that since they first started talking and the name just stuck.
马哈茂德是萨姆除了定好的周日外谈话最多的人。我们会在杂货店排队，马哈茂德会发短信说，我害怕，亚姆。我睡不着。他有那种小艾尔莫般的声音。虽然这些年来已经略有成熟，但当你读他的短信时，你几乎能听到那种细小的艾尔莫声音。有时他只会写，亚姆？亚姆？他从他们第一次开始谈话就一直这样称呼萨姆，这个名字就这样固定下来了。
Yemal's off the bus now, walking in Sadr City. He tells me to wait a second, a bomb just went off. I just want to see where it is, he says, hold on. I hear a man's voice very close speaking in Arabic and an ambulance gets loud, then moves away. They're not driving to the part of the city where Mahmood lives, so I don't have to be so nervous, Yemal says. It's a half hour bus ride from Mahmood's house to Yemal's. He says where Mahmood lives, there are about eight or nine explosions every day. And where he lives it's more like two or three.
耶马尔现在下车了，走在萨德尔城。他让我等一下，刚发生了炸弹爆炸。我只是想看看它在哪，他说，等等。我听到一个男人非常近的声音在说阿拉伯语，一辆救护车声音变大，然后移开。他们没有开往马哈茂德住的城市部分，所以我不用那么紧张，耶马尔说。从马哈茂德家到耶马尔家要坐半小时公交车。他说马哈茂德住的地方每天大约有八九次爆炸。而他住的地方大约两三次。
And how are you, Yemal asks. It's the question I find the most insinuating, the most difficult to answer.
那你呢，耶马尔问。这是我发现最让人动心、最难回答的问题。
Pretty good, just going to school and working at the dog daycare. Yemal tells me how weird it is I work with dogs. He seems annoyed every time Sam or I coo on the phone about something cute our dogs are doing.
挺好的，只是上学和在狗狗日托中心工作。耶马尔告诉我我和狗一起工作有多奇怪。每当萨姆或我在电话里对我们的狗做出的可爱举动咕咕叫时，他似乎都很恼火。
Here dogs are hated, Yemal says. If you come near them, they growl.
这里狗是令人讨厌的，耶马尔说。如果你靠近它们，它们会咆哮。
When you're putting together a body after an explosion, the dogs come and try to eat it all. You have to kill them. I kill a lot of dogs. I remember when Mahmood was in a coma once and bleeding, and the dog came nibbling on him and I killed him.
当你清理爆炸后的尸体时，狗会过来试图把它们全吃掉。你必须杀了它们。我杀了很多狗。我记得有一次马哈茂德昏迷不醒还在流血时，那只狗过来啃他，我就把它杀了。
Basically, people have a goat or a camel or a donkey or a horse. Once we had a hamster named Benjamin.
基本上，人们有山羊、骆驼、驴或马。曾经我们有一只叫本杰明的仓鼠。
Sam probably talks to the boys more than he talks to anybody. He always wanted brothers when he was a kid. Someone to play hide and seek with, to play guns with, or go somewhere dangerous. Sam says his relationship with the boys is like having brothers, but in a different way than he imagined back then. More intimate.
萨姆和男孩们的谈话可能比和任何人都多。他小时候总是想要兄弟。有人可以玩捉迷藏，玩枪，或者去危险的地方。萨姆说他和男孩们的这种关系就像拥有兄弟，但与他当时想象的方式不同。更亲密。
When Sadeem and Mahmood hit teenhood, they turn to Sam for advice. They translated the rush of hormones they were feeling into the English word, "drifts." So they'd ask Sam stuff like, how did you handle your drifts? And when will the drifts stop? He said something like, the drifts won't stop, you just learn how to deal with them and it gets easier after a while.
当萨迪姆和马哈茂德进入青少年时期，他们向萨姆寻求建议。他们把他们感受到的荷尔蒙冲动翻译成了英语单词“漂移”。所以他们会问萨姆诸如“你是怎么处理你的漂移的？漂移什么时候才会停止？”之类的问题。他说类似的话，漂移不会停止，你只是学会了如何应对它，过了一段时间就会变得容易一些。
Their friendship happened so gradually. Sam knows it's unusual, but it really only hits him how strange it is that he's so close with three people in the middle of a war when the boys tell them something especially disturbing about what they've seen, or when Sam tries to explain the phone calls to anyone here. He doesn't do that very often. Because when he's tried it's always seemed to backfire.
他们的友谊发展得如此渐进。萨姆知道这不寻常，但当男孩们告诉他一些关于他们所见过的特别令人不安的事情，或者当萨姆试图向这里的任何人解释这些电话时，他才真正意识到他和三个处于战争中的人如此亲近是多么奇怪。他并不经常这样做。因为当他尝试时，似乎总是适得其反。
When he told his parents he knew Iraqis, they seemed skeptical. And when it comes up with friends, some are interested, but others think it's weird and treat it like a joke. One night Sam was at the Twilight Lounge with a bunch of friends and Sadeem called. Sam's friend, Ana, asked who he was talking to that was so important. When he said it was one of his Iraqi friends, Ana said she wanted to talk to him. Sam had thought it was all in good fun, so he was like, all right, go ahead and say hi. And she said to Sadeem, say something dirty in Arabic to me. Sadeem was so angry. He said to Sam, why do you spend time with people like that? Why are there people like that?
当他告诉父母他认识伊拉克人时，他们显得很怀疑。当他在朋友中提到这件事时，有些人感兴趣，但其他人觉得很奇怪并把它当作笑话。一天晚上萨姆在暮光酒廊和一群朋友在一起，萨迪姆打了电话。萨姆的朋友安娜问他是谁在通话，这么重要。当他说这是他的一位伊拉克朋友时，安娜说她想和他说话。萨姆认为这只是闹着玩，所以他说，好的，去打个招呼吧。她对萨迪姆说，对我说些阿拉伯语脏话。萨迪姆非常生气。他对萨姆说，你为什么要和那样的人在一起？为什么会有那样的人？
On January 31, 2009, a year and a half ago, provincial elections held in 14 Iraqi provinces were celebrated in headlines as peaceful and almost violence free. But that morning, 17-year-old Sadeem told his friends and family in Baghdad, this is not a country. It's not a democracy. It's not peace here, nor is it more peaceful. There's no future here.
2009年1月31日，一年半前，在14个伊拉克省举行的省选举被头条新闻庆祝为和平且几乎没有暴力。但那天早上，17岁的萨迪姆告诉他在巴格达的朋友和家人，这不是一个国家。这不是民主。这里不是和平，也并没有更和平。这里没有未来。
He and his 16-year-old wife Rasheeda , who is pregnant with twins, pulled their adopted daughter, Yolena , out of preschool, quit their jobs, and signed on with a truck driver who said he would take them out of the country. Sadeem told me he left because he didn't want to raise his family in a city so violent. He and Rasheeda have now lost four of their six children. Although for reasons arguably unrelated to the war. Irina died in the womb. Ahmed , one of the twins, was premature and died 12 days after his birth. Their first adopted child, Abdul, passed away in 2008 due to a breathing problem. And their second adopted child, Yolena, who was deaf, partially blind, couldn't walk, and was expected to live only until the age of three, passed away from pneumonia two weeks ago at the age of six. The two other children are Yuwad who's one, and Saleem , who's almost two.
他和16岁的妻子拉希达，当时怀着双胞胎，把领养的女儿尤琳娜从幼儿园接走，辞去了工作，并签了一个卡车司机，他说会带他们离开这个国家。萨迪姆告诉我他离开是因为他不想在一个如此暴力的城市抚养他的家庭。他和拉希达现在已经失去了六个孩子中的四个。虽然原因可以说与战争无关。伊琳娜在腹中死亡。艾哈迈德，双胞胎之一，早产，在出生12天后死亡。他们的第一个领养孩子阿卜杜勒于2008年因呼吸问题去世。他们的第二个领养孩子尤琳娜，耳聋、部分失明、不能走路，预计只能活到三岁，两周前在六岁时因肺炎去世。另外两个孩子是尤瓦德，一岁，和萨利姆，快两岁了。
Saleem's also adopted. He was found on the steps of the child home and the workers called Sadeem and Rasheeda to see if they would take him. At first we said no because we already had Yolena and Yuwad Sadeem says. But then of course, they sent a damn photo of him. So a year ago, Sadeem and Rasheeda were saying goodbye to Baghdad. Sadeem can't say how long they spent in the hot, dark back of that truck with no bathroom, worrying over Yolena who was prone to seizures. But after a couple of days when the driver finally pushed them out, they realized they weren't in Kuwait or Saudi Arabia. There are still in Iraq, right near the western border.
萨利姆也是领养的。他在儿童之家的台阶上被发现，工作人员打电话给萨迪姆和拉希达看他们是否愿意收养他。起初我们说不，因为我们已经有了尤琳娜和尤瓦德，萨迪姆说。但后来，他们寄来了该死的一张他的照片。所以一年前，萨迪姆和拉希达正在和巴格达告别。萨迪姆无法说出他们在没有厕所、炎热阴暗的卡车后部呆了多久，担心着容易癫痫发作的尤琳娜。但在几天后，当司机终于把他们推下去时，他们意识到他们不在科威特或沙特阿拉伯。他们还在伊拉克，就在西边境附近。
After spending a few days in a refugee camp, they walked an hour to a village and decided to stay. They'd hoped to be counted among the 201 million Iraqi refugees who made it to Syria, or Jordan, or some other country. But instead, they're counted among the 2.8 million who have been displaced inside Iraq by the war.
在难民营呆了几天后，他们步行一小时到了一个村庄并决定留下来。他们曾希望被计入那201万逃到叙利亚、约旦或某些其他国家的伊拉克难民中。但相反，他们被计入了那280万在伊拉克境内因战争而流离失所的人数中。
Sadeem found a job almost right away teaching three- to five-year-olds at a mosque. They have to learn how to read the Quran in a specific way, to recite it like singing. He says the students are very, very behaved.
萨迪姆很快就找到了一份工作，在清真寺教三到五岁的孩子。他们必须学习如何以特定的方式阅读古兰经，像唱歌一样朗诵它。他说学生们非常有礼貌。
Sadeem says his new village is so calm. There are no soldiers, there's not much traffic. And he says, people aren't constantly worried about bombings. If you're at the grocery market and you stand in line with 15 people, it doesn't really matter because people take it easy, he says. It's not like in Baghdad where if there are two people in front of you, you're like, ah, there's two people in front of me. I'm going to die.
萨迪姆说他的新村庄非常平静。没有士兵，交通也不多。他说，人们并不总是担心爆炸。如果你在杂货店和15个人一起排队，这并不重要，因为人们很悠闲，他说。这不像在巴格达，如果有两个人排在你前面，你会想，啊，我前面有两个人。我要死了。
Back in Baghdad in early April, about three weeks after the elections Yemal was so upset about, he sent Sam a series of short text messages. He though he was in danger. There were people coming around his neighborhood. He didn't have many details and asked Sam to see what he could find out from news reports.
在四月初的巴格达，也就是耶马尔非常沮丧的选举大约三周后，他发给萨姆一系列简短的短信。他认为他处于危险之中。他家附近有一些人来过。他没有太多细节，要求萨姆看看他能从新闻报道中查到什么。
Sam found articles online about gunmen dressed at soldiers going door-to-door in neighborhoods near where Yemal's family lived, shooting and slitting the throats of Sunnis. Yemal is Sunni and Yemal's wife was just about to have her baby. She was in the hospital. So Yemal took his four-year-old daughter, Malika , and texted Sam that they were going to stay away from home for a while. Neither Sam nor Sadeem heard from Yemal or Mahmood for a few weeks after that. Finally they got word that little Malika was spotted by a neighbor wandering near some storefronts. She was taken to an uncle's house. Malika said she'd been with her father when there was a bomb and he told her to run.
萨姆在网上找到了关于打扮成士兵的枪手在耶马尔家人住的附近邻居挨家挨户射击并割断逊尼派喉咙的文章。耶马尔是逊尼派，耶马尔的妻子刚好要生孩子。她在医院。所以耶马尔带着他四岁的女儿马利卡，发短信给萨姆说他们要暂时离家避难。在那之后，萨姆和萨迪姆几周都没有收到耶马尔或马哈茂德的消息。终于他们得到消息说小马利卡被邻居发现在一些店面附近游荡。她被带到了一个叔叔家里。马利卡说当爆炸发生时她和她父亲在一起，他让她快跑。
So Sadeem took the 12 hour bus ride up to Baghdad to help in the search for his brothers. He wrote on his blog, where are you, Yemal? Where are you, Mahmood?
所以萨迪姆坐了12小时的公交车去巴格达寻找他的兄弟们。他在博客上写道，你在哪里，耶马尔？你在哪里，马哈茂德？
After he had returned to his village with no success, we heard from Sadeem's friends in Baghdad. Yemal's wife, Temara , had had her baby, a little girl, and was doing fine. Yemal and Mahmood had been found in a hospital. Mahmood injured but OK, recovering from an infection. Yemal in a deep coma with very little brain activity.
在他无果而终回到村庄后，我们从萨迪姆在巴格达的朋友那里得到了消息。耶马尔的妻子特马拉生下了她的孩子，一个小女孩，情况很好。耶马尔和马哈茂德被发现在一家医院里。马哈茂德受伤但没事，正从感染中恢复。耶马尔处于深度昏迷中，大脑活动非常微弱。
Months before all that, Yemal had chosen Sam to be an [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to his baby. Which is sort of like a godfather. Since Yemal is still in a coma and the baby's getting on a month and a half old, the responsibility falls on Sam, Sadeem and Mahmood to help Temara name her. So in early June Sadeem calls. He runs name ideas by Sam. What do you think about the name Leila. Leila? There's a very similar name in English and an Eric Clapton song.
在这一切发生的前几个月，耶马尔选择了萨姆作为他孩子的[未听清]。这有点像教父。由于耶马尔仍然昏迷不醒，而孩子已经一个半月大了，萨姆、萨迪姆和马哈茂德有责任帮助特马拉给她起名字。所以在六月初萨迪姆打了电话。他向萨姆提出了名字的想法。你觉得蕾拉这个名字怎么样？蕾拉？有一个英语歌曲和埃里克·克莱普顿的歌里有非常相似的名字。
Oh, Sadeem says.
噢，萨迪姆说。
Is that Temara is thinking about?
那是特马拉在想的吗？
No, it's what I'm thinking about.
不，这是我在想的。
I think that'd be a beautiful name.
我觉得那会是一个美丽的名字。
I don't know. That or otherwise I was thinking about the name Emina. But then I remembered you have a damn cat named that, says Sadeem.
我不知道。要不然我就在想埃米娜这个名字。但后来我想起你有一只该死的猫叫那个名字，萨迪姆说。
Sorry, did we ruin that name forever?
抱歉，我们永远毁了那个名字了吗？
Hefiza.
赫菲扎。
Say that name again.
再说一遍那个名字。
Hefiza.
赫菲扎。
What does hafiz mean again? Love?
哈菲兹又是什么意思？爱？
Yeah, it's the female version of hafiz.
是啊，这是哈菲兹的女性版本。
I'd be a pretty big fan of that name, Sam says.
我会是那个名字的忠实粉丝，萨姆说。
Well, I don't know. I'll give Temara a few names and then she'll see which one she want to name her. But she's such a good little fluffy baby.
好吧，我不知道。我会给特马拉几个名字，然后看她想给孩子起哪个。但她是个如此可爱的小软绵绵宝宝。
How's the mom doing?
妈妈怎么样？
She's OK. As good as she can be, I guess.
她还好。我想，在目前的情况下已经尽力了。
From the hospital In Baghdad, a friend puts the phone up to Yemal so Sam can speak to him. There's hope that even though Yemal's in a coma, he might hear and understand the voices of his friends. Sam tells Yemal that he loves him. As Sam talks he hears the machines that keeps his friend breathing. Yemal slept through his 23th birthday, May 29, His friends have been writing on his Facebook wall and I've been looking at the pictures.
从巴格达的医院，一位朋友把电话放到耶马尔耳边，以便萨姆能和他说话。人们希望即使耶马尔昏迷不醒，他也能听到并理解朋友的声音。萨姆告诉耶马尔他爱他。当萨姆说话时，他听到了维持他朋友呼吸的机器声。耶马尔在睡梦中度过了他23岁的生日，5月29日。他的朋友们一直在他的Facebook墙上留言，我一直在看照片。
The last thing Yemal posted was a cover the Aerosmith song, "Don't Want to Miss a Thing." A song I always thought was cheesy, so I never opened the link.
耶马尔发布的最后一件事是史密斯飞船的歌曲“不想错过任何东西”的翻唱。一首我一直觉得很俗气的歌，所以我从未打开那个链接。
So Yemal can't speak and Sadeem can only call when he visits Baghdad or Basra. Sam misses them, but he's still on the phone every week to Iraq for four hours. He's got a new schedule. Some Saturdays he talks to Mahmood. And on Sundays, he talks to their friends in Najaf. They tell him whatever news they have about the boys. Now they've become Sam's friends too.
所以耶马尔不能说话，而萨迪姆只有在访问巴格达或巴士拉时才能打电话。萨姆想念他们，但他仍然每周都要和伊拉克通四个小时的电话。他有了新的时间表。有些周六他会和马哈茂德谈话。周日，他会和他们在纳杰夫的朋友交谈。他们告诉他关于男孩们的任何新闻。现在他们也成了萨姆的朋友。
Sara Blaisdell lives in Virginia.
莎拉·布莱斯代尔住在弗吉尼亚州。
Act 3: Intergalactic cold call.
第三幕：星际冷通话。
First contact to science fiction fans means just one thing, first contact with extraterrestrials. And SETI, that's the Search for Extraterrestrials Intelligence, where scientists use radio telescopes to look for signs of intelligent life elsewhere, actually has a task force, the Post-Detection Task Force, devoted to the question, what happens if they find intelligent life elsewhere. And one of the responsibilities of this task force is actually to consider this question, what kind of message should we send as our first communication with an alien civilization.
对科幻小说迷来说，第一次接触意味着一件事，与外星人的第一次接触。而SETI，也就是搜寻地外智慧生命，科学家们使用射电望远镜寻找其他地方智慧生命的迹象，实际上有一个工作组，探测后工作组，致力于“如果他们在其他地方发现智慧生命会怎样”的问题。这个工作组的职责之一实际上就是考虑这个问题，作为我们与外星文明的第一次交流，我们应该发送什么样的信息。
So supposing we find that there is a radio source, or at least evidence for alien technology at some particular location in the galaxy--
所以假设我们发现有一个无线电来源，或者至少在银河系的某个特定位置有外星技术的证据——
This is Professor Paul Davies, author of a book about all this, The Eerie Silence and chair of this task force.
这是保罗·戴维斯教授，关于这一切的书《诡异的沉默》的作者，也是这个工作组的主席。
The the task group feels that in the first instance, we should not disclose the coordinates in the sky of this source, simply because we don't want any random crackpot setting themselves up as a self-appointed spokesperson of mankind and commandeering a radio telescope and sending their own homespun wisdom. Because if we're going to respond to some sort of contact like this, we have to think very carefully about what we want to say.
工作组认为，在第一种情况下，我们不应该披露该来源在天空中的坐标，仅仅是因为我们不希望任何随意的怪人把自己设立为人类的自封代言人，并征用射电望远镜发送他们自己的土法智慧。因为如果我们打算回应某种这样的接触，我们必须非常仔细地思考我们想说什么。
In your book you write, "A message concocted by a committee would be a recipe for the lowest common denominator, and is likely to consist of banalities. Statements solely by a politician or religious leaders to horrible to contemplate." What do you think should be in the first message?
你在你的书中写道，“一个委员会编写的信息将是最低共同点的处方，很可能包含陈词滥调。政治家或宗教领袖的单独声明太可怕了，无法想象。”你认为第一条信息里应该有什么？
I err on the side of comprehension. That is to say that I think we should pick a message which is certain to be understood by them and that we might pick one of the fundamental numbers that come out of atomic and quantum physics and send that as an indication of our level of understanding of basic science and mathematics.
我倾向于可理解性。也就是说，我认为我们应该选择一条他们肯定能理解的信息，我们可以选择原子物理学和量子物理学中的基本数字之一，并将其作为我们对基础科学和数学理解水平的标志发送。
Now if we attempted for example, to send details of the US Constitution or something of that sort, of course it would be completely incomprehensible. Some people think that music is the finest achievement of the human intellect, but music appreciation is so tied to the human cognitive system, it may just be completely meaningless to an alien brain an alien mind.
如果我们试图发送例如美国宪法的细节之类的东西，当然那将是完全不可理解的。有些人认为音乐是人类智慧的最高成就，但音乐鉴赏与人类认知系统联系太紧密，对一个外星大脑、一个外星思维来说可能完全毫无意义。
Send that stuff later, Davies says, once they're getting to know us. First message, be simple and comprehensible. Numbers. Sent in binary code, zero's and one's. But apparently not everybody on our planet has gotten this memo.
戴维斯说，等他们开始了解我们之后再发送那些东西。第一条信息，简单明了。数字。以二进制代码发送，零和一。但显然我们星球上的并非每个人都收到了这个备忘录。
Hi, my name is Venetia and I'm part of a groundbreaking new project that lets Bebo users make their mark on history.
嗨，我叫维内西亚，我是一个突破性的新项目的一部分，让Bebo用户在历史上留下他们的印记。
When you look into the night sky, there's a star 20 and 1/2 light years away.
当你望向夜空时，有一颗星星距离我们20.5光年。
This was on a social networking site called Bebo a little while back. There's a planet 20 light years away that this website says, theoretically could hold life. Maybe.
这是不久前在一个叫Bebo的社交网站上出现的。有一个距离我们20光年的行星，这个网站说，理论上可能拥有生命。也许吧。
We want you to create a message that we'll beam out of solar system and across the galaxy. In just over 20 years when the message arrives at our target planet, the photos, drawings, and words submitted by Bebo users could be the first things that another world ever learns about mankind.
我们希望你创造一条我们将发送出太阳系并穿越银河系的信息。在20多年后信息到达目标行星时，Bebo用户提交的照片、图画和文字可能是另一个世界了解人类的第一件事。
Well, we got a hold of some of these messages from Bebo users that were actually sent by a radio telescope to this distant alien civilization that they hope anyway, is there. Presumably, super advanced if the can hear and understand us. One of the messages here, "I don't believe in aliens. But I suppose if you're getting this now, I was epically wrong. P.S. We invented the George Foreman grill, therefore we're better than you."
嗯，我们掌握了一些Bebo用户的这些信息，它们实际上是由射电望远镜发送给这个遥远的外星文明的，他们希望无论如何，它就在那里。据推测，如果他们能听到并理解我们，那将是超级先进的。其中一条信息是，“我不相信外星人。但我猜如果你现在收到这个，我就错得太离谱了。附注：我们发明了乔治·福尔曼烤架，因此我们比你们强。”
Another, "George Sampson is amazing-- and then there's a smiley emoticon. He's so talented, lovely, and gorgeous. He's such an inspiration-- I'm reading it this way because there are exclamation marks by the way. He's such an inspiration to other dancers, plus deserves everything he's gotten. Congrats on everything, George, and good luck for the future. I love you, XX."
另一条，“乔治·桑普森太棒了——然后是一个笑脸表情。他如此有才华，可爱又华丽。他如此鼓舞人心——我这样读是因为顺便说一下那里有感叹号。他是其他舞者的灵感来源，而且理应得到他所拥有的一切。祝贺乔治的一切，祝未来好运。我爱你，XX。”
Another, "I love someone very much, but they got someone else."
另一条，“我深爱着某人，但他们有了别人。”
Another, "Anybody for a cup Of tea?"
另一条，“有人要来杯茶吗？”
Another, "You're lucky to live over 20 light years from Earth. By the time you read this, I will be getting my state pension and my country's capital, London, will be under water due to global warming melting our ice caps. The white bits that you see at the top and bottom of our planet. P.S. Don't invent/use fossil fuel based engines."
另一条，“你们很幸运住在距离地球20光年以上的地方。当你读到这个的时候，我将领到州养老金，而我国的首都伦敦将因为全球变暖融化冰盖而被淹没。你们在我们行星顶部和底部看到的白色部分。附注：不要发明/使用基于化石燃料的发动机。”
And this one, my favorite. "Hi aliens. If you get this and you get coordinates and stuff from Earth, please don't come and kill us because that's not nice. Thanks. Unless you kill us, then no thanks. From Morgan Nagle."
还有这条，我最喜欢的。“嗨，外星人。如果你收到这个，并从地球获得了坐标什么的，请不要来杀我们，因为那不友好。谢谢。除非你杀了我们，那就不谢谢了。来自摩根·纳格尔。”
People also sent pictures of themselves, of their guitars and drum sets. There's several stick figure drawings. There are lots of logos from sports teams. And a surprising number of photos of Heath Ledger as the joker.
人们还发送了他们自己的照片，他们的吉他和鼓组。有几张火柴人画。有很多体育队的标志。还有惊人数量的希斯·莱杰饰演小丑的照片。
In the cause of these exercises where messages have been invited using social networking sites--
在这些使用社交网站征集信息的活动中——
Again, Professor Paul Davies.
又是保罗·戴维斯教授。
--it's alarming and a bit depressing to see the sort of messages people send it. Mostly they're at the level of sentiments about their boyfriends or girlfriends or something of that sort.
——看到人们发送的那种信息，真是令人震惊且有点沮丧。它们大多处于关于他们的男朋友或女朋友之类的感伤水平。
I have to say that I, myself, don't have any great misgivings because I think the chances of these transmitted signals ever being picked up by an alien civilization are very small.
我必须说，我自己没有任何大的疑虑，因为我认为这些传输信号被外星文明接收到的机会非常小。
Also, he says, the aliens won't understand a word of it in all likelihood. He also takes a dim view of the space probes that NASA has sent out with messages for other civilizations. The Voyager spacecraft had an actual phonograph record with sounds from Earth. We've sent the Beatles song "Across the Universe " into space. The Pioneer spacecraft had a plague on it with drawings of a naked man and woman. The man's hand raised in greeting.
此外，他说，外星人很可能一个字也听不懂。他也对NASA发送给其他文明信息的空间探测器持怀疑态度。旅行者号航天器有一张真正的留声机唱片，上面有来自地球的声音。我们将披头士乐队的歌曲《跨越宇宙》发送到了太空。先驱者号航天器上有一块牌匾，上面有裸体男人和女人的图画。男人的手举起作为问候。
Davies was written about this in his book.
戴维斯在他的书中写过这一点。
The picture is dominated by the human shapes. Yet our physical form is probably the least significant thing we can say. It's almost completely irrelevant, both scientifically and culturally. To put it bluntly, who gives a damn what we look like? The raised hand is the height of absurdity. Such a culturally specific mannerism would be utterly incomprehensible to another species. Especially one that might not have limbs. This half-hearted attempt to put our stamp on the cosmic community is distinctive in its narrow-mindedness and preoccupation with 20th century science and human affairs.
这张图片以人类形状为主。然而我们的身体形态可能是我们能说的最不重要的事情。无论在科学上还是文化上，它几乎完全无关紧要。直白地说，谁在乎我们长什么样？举起的手是荒谬的巅峰。这种文化特定的礼仪对另一个物种来说将是完全不可理解的。特别是那些可能没有四肢的物种。这种在我们宇宙社区打上烙印的半心半意尝试，其狭隘和对20世纪科学及人类事务的关注是独特的。
For now though, since it seems that anybody can borrow one of these radio telescopes to beam out a message, what we're sending into space includes stuff like this from that Bebo project. "We have pointless sports such as golf. You hit a ball with a stick and aim for a hole. Also a game for the rich. Now we have fun games like rugby. We hurt each other for a ball to gain points. Football is a boring game to some and not to other, but if you think of it, all sports are pointless. Just something to keep us happy." [MUSIC- "FEELS LIKE THE FIRST TIME" BY FOREIGNER]
虽然目前，由于任何人似乎都可以借用这些射电望远镜来发送信息，我们发送到太空的内容包括来自Bebo项目的这种东西。“我们有像高尔夫这样毫无意义的运动。你用棍子打球并瞄准一个洞。也是富人的游戏。现在我们有像橄榄球这样有趣的游戏。我们互相伤害去争取一个球来得分。足球对有些人来说是无聊的游戏，对其他人不是，但如果你想想，所有运动都是毫无意义的。只是为了让我们快乐。”[音乐- 外国人乐队的“Feels Like The First Time”]
Well our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and me, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer Julie Snyder. Seth Lind who is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Jonathan Mitchell created our audio simulation of the sound that Scott heard with his cochlear implant in the open of today's show.
嗯，我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔洪、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿是我们的办公室经理。杰西卡·霍珀提供音乐帮助。乔纳森·米切尔在今天节目的开头创作了斯科特用人工耳蜗听到的声音的音频模拟。
[ACKKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where right now you can see more of the messages that Bebo users beamed up into space if you aren't already in space and seeing them already from space. Though, how likely is that really? This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你现在可以看到Bebo用户发送到太空的更多信息，如果你还没在太空里并且已经从太空看到了它们的话。虽然，那种可能性真的有多大呢？《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's ready to let the truth be known.
我们的节目由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生进行管理监督，他准备让真相大白。
I'm a terrible kisser. That's kind of my thing.
我接吻技术很烂。那是我的招牌。
I'm Ira Glass, be back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
Me too, dude. Me too.
我也是，伙计。我也是。
[MUSIC- "FEELS LIKE THE FIRST TIME" BY FOREIGNER]
[音乐- 外国人乐队的“Feels Like The First Time”]